[Música]
y hacemos un cambio para empezar con las
noticias de la economía de la mano de
jorge hurtado aquí en francés 24 las
buenas noches para usted jorge de tal
angela muy bien muy bien jorge vamos a
empezar hablando de eeuu el presidente
se reunió yo byd n con el presidente del
banco central en medio de la subida de
los precios es una reunión bastante
inusual y de hecho el presidente byte en
dijo que no va a interferir en la
política monetaria de eeuu y que va a
respetar la independencia de la reserva
federal de ese país el presidente va a
ir en dijo que si bien su principal
objetivo es combatir la inflación que lo
mantiene bajo en las encuestas de
popularidad admitió que ese trabajo es
de gerard powell y la fed con la
excepción de donald trump que criticó a
la fed en su momento la mayoría de
presidentes de la casa blanca han
buscado cómo preservar esta
independencia de la fed la reunión se da
cuando el dato de inflación en eeuu es
el más alto en 40 años y cuando powell
también es criticado por supuestamente
actuar tarde contra el aumento de los
precios
en otros temas luego de que la unión
europea acordara embargar el 90 por
ciento de importaciones de petróleo ruso
para finales
hay reacciones en rusia bueno según los
mercados rusos aunque era una noticia
que ellos ya estaban esperando al final
del día lo va a terminar beneficiando a
sofía donets economista jefe para rusia
de renaissence capital dijo que el
momento de los precios del el aumento a
los precios del petróleo podría
beneficiar a rusia y esta pérdida de
ingresos podría compensarse con el
repunte de los precios mundiales según
ella es europa quien sufriría como
importadora de petróleo de los países
europeos acordaron recordar el 90 por
ciento de las importaciones de petróleo
de rusia lo que representa la sanción
más dura impuesta a moscú desde la
invasión de ucrania hace tres meses para
algunos expertos esto supondría pérdidas
por 70.000 millones de euros anuales
para rusia bueno y esto también es se
venía previendo israel y emiratos árabes
firmaron un histórico acuerdo sobre
libre comercio cuéntanos por favor bueno
y se firma también me dio una escalada
de violencia en los territorios ocupados
de jerusalén oriental y cisjordania es
histórico porque es el primero de este
tipo entre el estado judío y un país
árabe y elevará el intercambio bilateral
a unos diez mil millones de dólares en
cinco años para los emiratos árabes son
ricos en petróleo el acuerdo con israel
representa su segundo tratado bilateral
de libre comercio ante firmó uno similar
con india en febrero pasado los árabes
mantienen negociaciones comerciales
bilaterales con otros países como
indonesia y corea del sur y real y de
emiratos árabes unidos- establecieron
restablecieron los lazos en septiembre
del 2020 en un acuerdo que fue mediado
por eeuu y que fue de hecho propuesto
por donald trump escuchamos
israel y emiratos árabes unidos-
finalizaron hoy las negociaciones para
un acuerdo de libre comercio que
abarcará el 95 por ciento de los
productos comercializados entre ambos
países es un gran privilegio concluir
las negociaciones hoy para formular un
acuerdo completo e integral con los
emiratos árabes un acuerdo innovador el
primero de este tipo con un estado árabe
para el cierre de mi país en américa
latina' el peso colombiano tomó fuerza
después de la primera vuelta de las
elecciones jorge tanto el peso
colombiano como la bolsa de valores de
colombia cerraron al alza el peso cerró
con una subida del 4,16 por ciento a
tres mil setecientos setenta pesos por
dólar representa su mayor subida diaria
desde diciembre de 2010 y su valor más
fuerte frente al dólar desde el 20 de
abril de este año los activos
colombianos también se dispararon esto
luego de la primera ronda electoral
hacia la presidencia el candidato
rodolfo hernández prometió tomar medidas
contra la corrupción y el despilfarro en
el estado asegura que colombia debe
pagar sus deudas entre sus propuestas
está reducir el impuesto al valor
agregado del 19 por ciento al 10 por
ciento por su parte el candidato por la
izquierda gustavo petro ha dicho que
quiere eliminar gradualmente la
exploración petrolera algo que afectaría
a la estatal ecopetrol que hoy subió un
9% en la apertura por la posibilidad de
que esa propuesta no se concrete en la
segunda ronda esto comentó andrés moreno
él es economista y analista bursátil
tras las elecciones presidenciales la
primera vuelta los mercados en colombia
reaccionaron muy positivos el dólar en
colombia tuvo una caída en promedio de
más de 135 pesos es decir ese se
valorizó el peso colombiano es la mayor
caída en pesos en la historia del dólar
en colombia eso se llama confianza el
mercado de capitales y en especial el
dólar habían acumulado una gran
preocupación
por temas electorales eso ya se ha ido
apagando por los resultados electorales
donde el contrincante de petro es muy
posible que lo derrote y lo segundo es
que las acciones se dispararon hoy había
un rebalanceo de un índice internacional
el msc y colombia pero salieron
pluralidad de compradores normalmente
conocer en su rebalanceo las acciones
cae en este caso hubo compradores y
personas creyendo en colombia
a largo plazo
[Música]